you and Kendall are really good friends
now right yeah been friends for a while
yeah yeah oh yes that's sweet that y'all
are still really good friends yeah yeah
kendall Jenner came up in Harry Styles
sit down with Ellen DeGeneres and things
got real uncomfortable maybe Kendall and
Harry who have never officially
confirmed their past rumored romance sat
down for a game of spill your guts on
The Late Late Show when Harry was
filling in for host James Corden dying
to know this which songs on your last
album were about me
oh yeah she went there ooh Harry and
Kendall were rumoured to be dating in
2016 at the time a source close to
Kendall told ET that she was the one to
make the first move in st. Barths on New
Year's Eve I think they're dating yes
yeah and then there was that I don't
know if they're like
boyfriend/girlfriend you know nowadays I
don't I don't know people are weird with
stuff so I don't know their title but I
mean they were in st. Barths together
hanging out so to me that's dating I
would call that data
okay now fast-forward to Harry's
interview with Ellen so when you hosted
for James Corden you your guests were
Tracee Ellis Ross and and Kendall Jenner
and and you and Candler are really good
friends now right
yeah Wow yeah yeah that's sweet that
y'all are still really good friends yeah
yeah and now yeah yeah I think so yeah
yeah all right all right yeah okay
I mean if adorably awkward isn't a thing
Harry just made it a thing also nothing
says I'm nervous with this line of
questioning like a quick reach for the
water anyhoo Harry released his new
album fine line last week
[Music]
the album is rumored to be inspired by
his 2018 breakup with model Camille Rowe
and don't worry guys
Allen made sure to ask about all that -
some people are saying word on the
street is that this album is all about a
breakup from someone okay so the
question is is it I mean I think like I
definitely write from personal
experience I think a lot of people do I
think if you want your songs to kind of
be honest and connecting people it's
usually from writing honestly right yeah
it's definitely about kind of I guess
what I was going through at the time and
that's both good and bad Harry even
included a real life of voicemail that
he once got from his French ex on the
song cherry
[Music]
translate it to English hey are you
asleep oh I'm sorry
well no nope it's not important well
then we went to the beach and now we
perfect
Harry dished about the creative choice
during a recent interview with Apple
musics Zane Lowe cuz they go add it in
later on and it felt so part of the song
it just felt like it needed it with
friends and stuff so I asked her if it
was okay and she was okay with it
it was old part of like being my
outcomes and he echoed all that during
his chat with Ellen this album for me it
was while I was making it the times when
I was kind of sad will probably like
some of the saddest times of my life but
then at the same time the times when I
was happy with some of the best times
I've ever had in my life
so it's it's both it's a fine line
that's the name of the album fine line
and it all comes full circle folks of
course you can count on et to bring you
all the latest news on Harry and Kendall
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stephens
see you soon
[Music]